it is a country rich in tourist
attractions all that japan lacks other
tourists
tokyo's takiji outdoor fish market has
relied on local visitors throughout the
pandemic
before the pandemic 80 to 90 percent of
our customers were from overseas so we
are looking forward to seeing foreigners
come back again
the same goes for all businesses relying
on the tourism industry like this tour
bus company
our bus tours for japanese tourists have
been cut back and we've had to stop
foreign language tours all together
it's a long way from former prime
minister shinzo abe's dream of becoming
a world leading tourism destination all
geared to the 2020 summer olympics that
he helped to secure
for a while japan was on track to
meeting its tourism ambitions in 2019 it
recorded well over 30 million visitors
and was fully expecting to reach its
goal of 40 million arrivals in 2020 when
the pandemic happened
ironically the start of the pandemic
that decimated the tourism sector was
heralded by an outbreak on a cruise ship
that had docked in yokohama
the olympics were delayed by a year
while the country virtually closed its
borders the area which was the athlete's
village is now under development as
memories fade of those ill-fated games
and japan can look ahead to reopening to
tourism once more cautiously
the reopening will happen gradually and
first with package stores organized with
the travel agencies
fears that a rushed reopening might see
a resurgence in covid19 cases don't seem
to bother a population apparently
suffering pandemic fatigue
of course i worry about covert but
overall it's a good thing
i'll continue being cautious but i've
had enough of this
corona may continue but we can't be
afraid of it we have to carry on with
our lives
most people seeming to believe that as
one of the world's most developed
nations it's time to open up to the
world once more rob mcbride al jazeera
tokyo